ميدان للبحاره المخضرمين وعشاق سباق
القوارب
هنا على ارض جزيره مارتنك في البحر
الكاريبي خلايا نحل ابطالها هذه القوارب
ببحارها المهاره جزيره مارتنك الفرنسيه
الواقعه شرق الكاريبي الى الشمال من
ترينيداد وتوباكو يزيد عدد سكانها على 400
الف نسمه الحدث الابرز بين سكان هذه
الجزيره هو سباقات هذه القوارب الشراعيه
واحد من اهم البحاره هنا وخبير في صناعه
القوارب والاشرعه لديه قارب فريد يدعيون
تم بناؤه في الاصل من اجل الذهاب الى
البحر لصيد الاسماك لكنه مع الوقت تحول
الى زورق سباقات
مجهود ضخم يبذل هنا للفوز بالسباق في
المقدمه يوجد موجه القارب لتوجيه قائد
الزورق فيما يخص الرياح وزاويه الشراع وفي
منتصف المركب مجموعه من المتسابقين لتفريغ
المياه من المركب حتى لا يزيد الماء من
وزن القارب
[موسيقى]
وا
البحاره وحدها على المركب ليست كافيه
لتقديم افضل اشكال الاداء والفوز
بالسباقات فالقوارب نفسها تمتلك دورا
محوريا وصناعتها لها اسرار وخبايا حتى
انها تصنع في اماكن سريه حتى لا تكشف
للاخرين فحمايه هذه الاسرار تحدث الفارقه
احيانا
لا يسبب
[موسيقى]
في كل عام تشتعل مارتنك باكملها للمشاركه
في هذه السباقات وهو اهم حدث رياضيا على
الجزيره يستذكر فيه السكان علاقتهم
الفريده مع البحر